ron y hermione y están practicando
levantar plumas en el aire con magia
gema yo ni puede levantar una pluma 35
pies sobre el aire lo cual es cinco
veces más alto que la altura a la que
rompo de levantar una pluma qué tan alto
puede roll levantar una pluma con magia
y lo podemos pensar de la siguiente
manera si nosotros sabemos que gema
johnny puede levantar 35 pies y esto es
5 veces más alto que ron lo que podemos
hacer es dividir estos 35 pies entre las
cinco veces que es más alto y con esto
tendríamos que si multiplicamos 5 por 7
es igual a 35 es decir que ron puede
levantar la pluma 7 pies vamos a ver la
respuesta
si ustedes tienen alguna duda de
cualquier manera aquí pueden ver los
tips aquí tenemos tres disponibles y
estos nos indican justamente lo que
acabamos de hacer donde germán y poder
levantar cinco veces están dividiendo el
total de jerma johnny entre cinco piezas
cuánto será cada una de estas distancias
divididas vamos a ver la siguiente nos
indica que puede ser un problema de
multiplicación justo lo que hicimos 5
porque número es decir estas cinco
piezas cuánto han de valer para que al
multiplicar por 5 tengamos 35 y también
nos indica que de manera más directa lo
podemos dividir tal como lo hicimos 35
entre 5 esto nos dará un resultado
esto nos dará un resultado donde 35
entre 5 es igual a 77 77 77 será igual a
35 o 7 por 5 es igual a 35 con eso
tendremos la respuesta final 7 pies